it's better to be unhappy alone
than unhappy with someone
i don't know who invented high heels
but all women owe him a lot
the nicest thing for me is sleep
then at least i can dream
imperfection is beauty
madness is genius
and it's better to be absolutely
ridiculous than absolutely boring
give a girl the right shoes and she can
conquer the world
success makes so many people hate you
i wish it wasn't that way
it would be wonderful to enjoy success
without seeing envy in the eyes of those
around you
i don't mind living in a man's world
as long as i can be a woman in it
sex is a part of nature
i go along with nature
[Music]
if i'd observed all the rules
i'd never have gotten anywhere
one of the best things that ever
happened to me is that i'm a woman
that is the way all females should feel
fear is stupid
so are regrets
a strong man doesn't have to be dominant
toward a woman
he doesn't match his strength against a
woman weak with love for him
he matches it against the world
beauty and femininity are ageless and
can't be contrived
and glamour although the manufacturers
won't like this cannot be manufactured
not real glamour it's based on
femininity
[Music]
a career is wonderful but you can't curl
up with it on a cold night
hollywood is a place where they'll pay
you a thousand dollars for a kiss
and 50 cents for your soul
[Music]
a kiss without love
is just a mutual exchange of saliva
the body is meant to be seen
not all covered up
we should all start to live before we
get too old
i have feelings too
i am still human
all i want is to be loved for myself and
for my talent
i think that sexuality is only
attractive when it's natural and
spontaneous
respect is one of life's greatest
treasures i mean what does it all add up
to if you don't have that
no one ever told me i was pretty when i
was a little girl
all little girls should be told they're
pretty
even if they aren't
if you can make a girl laugh you can
make her do anything
a woman can't be alone
she needs a man
a man and a woman support and strengthen
each other
she just can't do it by herself
before marriage a girl has to make love
to a man to hold him
after marriage she has to hold him to
make love to him
fame doesn't fulfill you
it warms you a bit but that warmth is
temporary
naturally there are times when every
woman likes to be flattered to feel she
is the most important thing in someone's
world
only a man can paint this picture
being a sex symbol is a heavy load to
carry
especially when one is tired hurt and
bewildered
if i'm a star
then the people made me a star
when it comes to gossip
i have to readily admit men are as
guilty as women
the real lover is the man who can thrill
you by just touching your head or
smiling into your eyes
or just by staring into space
[Music]
dreaming about being an actress is more
exciting than being one
i once wanted to prove myself by being a
great actress
now i want to prove that i'm a person
then maybe i'll be a great actress
[Music]
you